Ja das lernen der zukunft heute ist es ja noch
So rein den klassenraum und schon muss man das handy abgeben
Tja in der zukunft wird es wahrscheinlich anders aussehen künstliche intelligenz wird die klassen sind wir übernehmen
und maschinen werden in den schulalltag integriert
vieles läuft über das internet zum beispiel die hausaufgaben dafür wird die schulpflicht und das sitzenbleiben abgeschafft aber
Ihr habt euch dieses thema bei whatsapp gewünscht und bekommt jetzt alle wichtigen facts zum thema wie sieht der schulalltag wohl in
50 und wie sie der in 100 jahren aus jetzt im pixum science fiction herzlich willkommen
Kinder werden dann wohl schon sehr früh gefördert es gibt hauptsächlich private kitas und schulen die träger sind nicht mehr die städte und kommunen sondern
bildungs der lage oder medienunternehmen die eltern bekommen ein großes mitspracherecht die lehrerinnen und lehrer haben
dagegen kaum noch etwas
zu sagen ihre rolle wird sich wohl schon in naher zukunft extrem wandeln den forschungsteams weltweit stellen immer wieder fest dass
lehrer und lehrerinnen schülern allein nicht helfen könnten stattdessen werden sie zu coaches
also
zu
Lernhilfen die individuell mit den schülerinnen und schülern die nächsten lernziele besprechen und ein zeitlimit dafür ansätzen anders als sollte
Werden sie wohl nicht mehr verbeamtet sondern bekommen zeitverträge obwohl das hat ja schon angefangen zudem haben sie die pflicht sich
Regelmäßig weiterzubilden das finde ich auch eine ziemlich gute sache zusätzlich zum lehrerkollegium wird es wohl mentoren geben also ehemalige
schülerinnen und schüler und
Bekannte oder verwandte die die kinder beim lernen unterstützen sitzenbleiben gibt es nicht mehr
genauso wenig wie die noten von 1 bis 6 auch die schulgebäude
ändern sich grundlegend zumindest von innen es gibt keine einzelnen klassenräume mehr sondern große
lernlandschaften die schall wende in einzelnen bereichen und dateien mittendrin unzählige computer
Laptops tablets und so weiter und so fort die kinder lernen in altersgemischten gruppen vor allem aber auch in arbeitsgruppen über das internet
Im netz trifft man sich mit anderen schülerinnen und schülern weltweit und betrifft beispielsweise
Mit mit schülerinnen und schülern aus japan die ansätze des buddhistischen glaubens wie gesagt die freie wirtschaft wird sich auch in der schullandschaft
Durchsetzen die eltern sind es jetzt die die
Entscheidungen treffen welche schule bitte die themen an die für mein kind besonders spannend sind die eltern sind es auch die
Bildungspaket buchen und aufstocken manche forschungsteams sind der überzeugung dass es in 50 jahren eine art standard
bildungsangebot geben wird er quasi wie eine pflicht krankenkasse falls die eltern und schüler mehr wollen kann gegen geld
aufgestockt werden und beispielsweise eine bildungsreise nach china gebucht werden ein teil kann beispielsweise auch über
bildungsgut einer oder stipendien finanziert werden und weil die staatliche hand raus ist ist
auch die schulpflicht längst abgeschafft die eltern und schüler können selbst entscheiden ob sie zur schule gehen oder die neuesten erkenntnisse aus der neurobiologie
Lieber von zu hause aus lernen bestimmt wird dafür, so etwas wie eine
Art unterrichtspflicht geben so dass die lernziele zu einem bestimmten zeitpunkt x von staatlicher seite
Abgefragt werden die schulen haben bis spät abends geöffnet und sind so wie heute auch vor allem ein sozialer treffpunkt zudem gibt es wohl von
wissenschaftlicher sicht aus die möglichkeit seine eigenen denkt fähigkeiten testen zu lassen bin ich eher der
optische oder eher der akustische typ daraufhin ausgerichtet können dann die lerninhalte vermittelt werden und das wohl bis zu
Zehnmal schneller als heute
in weiteren 50 jahren also von jetzt an aus in 100 jahren gesehen wird der schulalltag noch einmal ganz anders aussehen einige bildungs forschungs
experten gehen davon aus dass dann künstliche
Intelligenz das lehrern übernommen haben wird und ja das kann ich mir persönlich sehr gut vorstellen und zwar nicht nur im bereich der schule die
Wissenschaftler um rosa kinn von der londons global university geht allerdings davon aus dass
Intelligente computer die lehrer an sich nicht zu hundert prozent setzen sie aber sehr gut unterstützen könnten
kopfrechnen und so weiter gehört dann wohl sehr wahrscheinlich auch der vergangenheit an denn die gesellschaft hat wohl spätestens in 100 jahren
folgendes erkannt die menschen sollten sich auf das konzentrieren was sie wirklich können den rest übernehmen computer ich finde das sind hammer
Perspektiven wenn er als erster erfahren wollte man das alles realität wird dann meldet euch hierbei whatsapp an dann erfahrt ihr vor allen andern von
mir vom neuesten video eben vorab garantiert ihr könnt dort direkt in der redaktion von klicks und mitmachen und mit themen vorschlagen oder
über abstimmungen mitbestimmen einfach hier draufklicken und natürlich nicht das aber mit der
Genau mit der glocke vergessen hier geht es weiter mit dafür auch
draufklicken die fünf besten lernmethoden unbedingt ansehen ansonsten würde ich mal sagen bis dann
bleibt dran